c'était la seule corinne disponible ce
soir car l'autre corinne touzet pour
remettre maintenant le césar des
meilleurs costumes
corinne masiero
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi bah c'est vous donne j'aime
être le césar du meilleur costume peau
d'âne c'est bien c'est mythique ah ouais
ouais ouais ouais ligue 1 pourquoi tu
disais déguster vegan non enfin c'est
pas le sens non c'est pour moi
moi j'avais dit je voulais la robe
catherine deneuve dans peau d'âne la
robe couleur de soleil originaux c'est
trop cher c'est pas assez essentiel ah
ouais parce essentiel catherine deneuve
dans le cinéma français peut-être un mot
dinan baissez vous énervez pas comme
d'habitude je ne vais pas m'énerver
vous avez qu à choper à tigre à viola
qui traînent puis vous faites at y des
rayures la faire un costume avec atik tu
chevauchent tu vois tu la fourche comme
dit l'autre tu prends sa peau puis tu
fais à costumes pour un autre film
par exemple je sais pas car the rogues
roi de la jungle
en plus de ça chez nous c'est fini alors
j'applaudis dgt a demandé n'avez pas des
costumes suis allé au théâtre de l'odéon
cet après-midi les kopa qui occupent ils
m'ont dit t'as qu'à propre ça il ya une
femme qui est passé soit disant pour
négocier voilà c'est trop trash trop
sanglant
je suis ménopause et moi non mais tu as
raison c'est trop trash peau d'âne et on
va pas se mentir
qui c'est qui va financer peau d'âne
aujourd'hui à l'histoire d'un père qui
veut cela et que sa fille pour la doc et
personnes il va financer ça au cnc
peut-être bah ouais bah ouais c'est pas
de moi le blog pas voilà donc si non
mais je vais arrêter parce qu'on va dire
je suis sur la mauvaise dépense et mode
époque j'aime bien alors j'ai un autre
costume si tu veux si je suis là être
les ports c'est plus cinéphiles à c'est
carrie au bal du diable ça va c'est trop
trash aussi page et le dernier a pris de
ne plus un dernier c'est qui veut la
peau de roger la thermite en est là
parce que maintenant on est comme savent
tout mais voilà est sous l'eau
alors c'est important que si on a l'air
con quand on en a pas c'est vrai voilà